two three Khloe Kardashian and Tristan
Thompson are quarantined together and
celebrating their little girl yep the
exes came together to throw their
daughter true at rolls slash Sesame
Street team's second birthday bash at
Coco's house on Sunday memories
the reality star shared tons and I mean
tons of throwback pics of her little
girl on her instace Tori's including a
few of Tristan - Chloe decorated truths
room with tons of pink balloons and just
check out those cakes yeah
cakes plural like one two cakes and
Tristan was right there to help a little
true blow out the candles did you make a
wish the proud mama also shared this
instapoll switch included a bunch of
super cute pics of true she captioned
the post in part quote you are literally
my entire world I can't believe you are
- you make my life complete and I can't
wait to have forever with you
um cutest mom ever award of course Chloe
and Tristan split in February 20 19 min
his cheating scandal with Kylie Jenner's
former bestie
Jordan woods you know things happen and
of course I'm sorry and apologetic as
much as I can be in
you know and in a recent episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians Khloe
said she's so not interested in dating
are you dating anybody know what I'm
thinking about it no you've been on a
date no stop
well not since interestin and I broke up
yeah yeah
I have friends like I want to hook you
up with someone I just don't care I'm
focusing on myself and true but like
that's just what I do
yeah who knows maybe I'll never date
again
Khloe that's right who needs a man you
do you Khloe
I just find it so strange that people
find it such a negative when somebody
wants to be single trust me if I wanted
to date I would date I want to invest my
energy and my daughter and my
self-healing and I think that should be
really empowering and it should be more
rewarded rather than frowned upon and
all that echoes what Khloe told et back
in October you guys have been through so
much in your life but what do you look
what are you looking for now you're not
looking I'm not but I'm not like in ten
I'm just super happy and content and I'm
focused on work and like taking care of
me my body and soul and true and I just
I'm having so much fun with her and what
I want to I will it's not some
deliberate thing that I think that hard
about as for her relationship with
Tristan the two are just working on
co-parenting their adorable little girl
I think working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever mission and I always want to
evolve and grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people while the world is changing
around us we should adapt to that too
but always remember to be kind and just
courteous of what's happening around you
too
so I don't ever want that to change
[Music]